guys I'm going to let you go because you
have wouldn't you like to get some uh
part of this interview that's
usable this is what you're you're a
young lad you haven't you've listened to
some of my I'm I'm GNA say this is my
favorite episode maybe ever this is my
of my certainly this is a spectacular
episode I'm just going back over why
we're doing it it's because of your
admiration for me and my this a very
very famous podcast I I understand that
I know that and so we should be
to be part of it you couldn't get it you
couldn't say it with a straight face hey
I see after this let's you and me go and
cash our checks let's do it but we need
a big Bank yeah I mean not every I have
ID and maybe we'll get some cash and
some just a cashier's check yeah yeah
and I and I have a servant with me he
could carry the
bullion you know you guys have always
kept in touch that's what I like about
you you never got in the bubble you're
out there oh I'm of the people it's
always kept in touch with whom what do
you mean you're just in touch with the
people you know what I mean you're going
to the bank you'll have probably have to
stop and get a
wheelbarrow but uh but you do it in a
humble way would you say that with
success you
changed I I'm
pausing uh you can't help but change but
I I I'd say I have changed for the
better with success that's what I think
that's great yeah yeah I mean you
probably disagree I was gonna say I
can't can't wait to when did you did you
know Steve I mean you I met him uh on
Three Amigos 85 July yeah Jes yeah I did
and then we became great friends and
then you make that decision of whether
you're going to just have that to
experience of making a movie and never
see someone again or not and I think we
both chose to keep hanging it's just
interesting you bring up Three Amigos
because you make that movie it it came
out and it you know did what it did but
then it goes on and I don't know when it
happened but within maybe 10 years of it
coming out there's this whole generation
that seizes that movie and says this is
one of our favorite movies and it has
grown since then in a way that I think
is welld deserved but it's kind of
fascinating to me did you were you aware
of that happening that's what happens
with a lot of my movies except for the
10e part where they like
it well I've always found that you never
know if a movie is a is a hit or success
till 10 years goes by CU some movies are
big hits when they come out and then you
never hear of them again right and then
some movies tend to grow I was surprised
in fact we got a call from a magazine in
London
and they said we want to it was a film
magazine they said we want to put you
Marty and Chevy on the cover it was and
and we said why they said well it's the
25th anniversary of Three Amigos I said
you care and that's when I started
noting that there was some kind of right
thing happening with it yeah it's got
this whole other life and I'm I don't I
can't tell you how many times I've seen
they'll ask various rock musicians
artists um you
know fleets just anyone politicians list
favorite movies and then Three Amigos
keeps popping up in there which is
really great well Steve wrote
it well with Lauren Michaels and Randy
Newman that's right that's right but you
said you wrote the funniest parts I will
that's actually Randy Newman wrote my
favorite joke in the whole thing and
it's when El Guapo that's his birthday
and I all all his men are celebrating
and he opens a package and he goes it's
a sweater
I love the canteen joke so much that
you're both you you know the the three
of you are running out of water oh Cen
the canteen and just there's there's you
barely enough and then just
luxuriating spit out yeah lip balm is so
fantastic my my favorite joke is that we
go into a saloon that's filled with uh
bad
guys and we're all in our spangly
outfits and I go up to the bartend and
say excuse me we're not
Mexicans we're we're from out of
town was it fun to make yeah it was yeah
it was we were actually you know in
Arizona and on locations and building
these beautiful sets yeah it's just one
of those uh because sometimes I've known
when you're having a blast making
something I've I sometimes get worried
if you're having a really good time
making something that this means it
won't be good one of my favorite lines I
just somebody reminded me of it too at
the end the very end I go up to Patrice
Martinez who's a beautiful actress who
played Karma and she passed away
unfortunately and there's supposed to be
like something between us and I go up
and we're about to ride off and I say to
her um I'll be back one day and she says
why
well guys what's the plan for the rest
of the day I'm sure you've blocked out a
whole um chunk of time with me well it's
I'm I've got to do my
5bx workout oh incredible going to say
you look amazing thank you and it's
today it's AB day so I'm going to work
on the
ABS and that's most of the day yeah I
just I hard for me for you when you say
that for me not to think of your role on
a rested Dev development where your
uncle the yeah the bullet you know uh
shoot me shoot me and um my son adors
that show so the times that you've been
around as much as you've done you never
know what's going to get people and he's
you seen and really liked your other
work but but you as the bullet the
bullet whatever isn't that I was a guy I
was not so old I was their uncle that my
legs didn't work and I had to be carried
around strong man and we kept adding
jokes and at one point I said
to the nuts and they put me down to
Jason bait's you know testicles and I
went Bridge mix Bridge mix and I me they
put me on a table to
eat but it's just so nice that you do
these different things you never know
what's going to catch with who and then
you know my son who now was 17 but at
the time he was seeing it he was like 12
and he was like well this is the
funniest thing I've ever seen and I'm
like well he's he's at the you know he's
coming over tonight and it's just it's
lovely it's very nice gentlemen okay
thank you Conan I uh I want to let you
go thank you very much think about the
Cameo uh oh of course I will play a
small part M I have a tendency to shoot
the lens I look right into the lens wow
good how would it be um STK like monster
crushes Town people and then is arrested
for murder something like that okay but
I I like I go you why do I ask for more
I like Conan's approach cuz most actors
try not to look into the lens yes I
would be have a small roll where I'm
literally carrying crab cakes in the
background at the nice Westside
apartment and I stop and I turn and look
right into the lens and freeze that's
what we're going to do oh Steve's taking
a call no no oh no I I'm looking at the
my plans for the rest of the day cuz you
asked and then I realize I have none
okay well perfect okay um thanks a thank
you very much uh guys um you both mean
the world to me and this is uh like I I
don't know we will never top this
episode and I know that you being
self-effacing and saying we've killed
time this an absolute Joy absolute Joy I
bow to both love I bow to you well
that's not good question and obviously
we've both been influencers but which
one a little bit more oh me you can't
see everybody he's at me thanks Conan no
anyway Steve your cars
here